this is Rick Fest and lose everything
the whole house has fallen and uh look
at Prague it's just been a bad run for
him this is what when tilt happens okay
what's happening here from Anish giri
he's just a spectacular moves here he
even gives up another Rook just to lure
away white Bishop
and uh yeah we will see Checkmate now in
a few moves we're actually going to see
checkmates well I think but maybe Anish
will just take the safe simple approach
he's just going to win some material
here you can even trade off the Queen's
win White's rook in the corner with the
Black Brook yeah maybe we won't go for
checkmate Gary takes the safe approach
and uh yeah he's up a rook for a night
and a couple of Pawns
Prague it's over and he takes the win
wow winning the third game in a row on
each Geary takes the lead in The Blitz
tie breaks five minutes that is correct
Anish until Blitz game number two which
will be must win for Prague he will have
the white pieces he stays by the